[Music]
and here is some good news if you're one
of those people who's ever sent a bad
text message or you granted it or you
made a mistake
apple plans to let iphone users unsend
or edit messages in their latest
software update that'll be coming this
fall here's the catch so you only have
15 minutes to act to unsend or edit so
what does this mean if you're one of
those people who ends up in a chaotic
argument in a group chat or even worse
yet a family group chat
i know i know i've sent accidental text
messages to other people that i wish
that i could unsend it's kind of like oh
hey sorry that was meant for somebody
else but greg yes word on the street is
this is a habit for you that you either
text or call certain people thinking
that they're actually someone else no
that has never happened i don't know
who's feeding you these lies i got my
intel sources yes let me just say that i
need
a bigger solution would be a
breathalyzer on your phone
there you go
so many risky posts and texts that
happen after a little bit of liquid
courage i think the more dangerous thing
is this the
autocorrect because the autocorrect
takes the worse that you're actually
saying and then it flips it so let's say
it always flips gave into have
that changes everything especially if
you're talking about a skin condition
how about you jesse this is this is
something you're unfamiliar with no i
wish my mother had had this a few times
because i got some nasty messages i have
a question though so if you send the
text and you're within the 15 minutes
right
does that mean the the receiver of the
text
will they have seen what you sent
and then you can go back and edit it
because
yeah if they see what you said and then
you go back and edit it then it's kind
of it's not the same it's like a secret
it's like a secret stealth edit after an
article comes out watching him post
right right
i think the idea is that if you send it
and it's red immediately then you can't
oh okay if it's not red you have those
15 minutes however here's the here's the
other catch is uh if if i send you a
message i've updated to the new
operating system you have not
and i
unsend it
i'll think you didn't see it but you'll
still see it yeah you got to have both
both sides um both sides have to be
catching in um i think it would be most
useful for things like when you spell
your y-o-u-r but you meant y-o-u
apostrophe because it's crazy so
embarrassing i love that i
just to find out who's really really
annoying
one of those kind of people judge how
about you you know what i think i think
it it's a prosecutor in me doesn't want
any of it gone away because in order to
prove my case i have to prove that they
admitted that there was a confession
it's all there and they shouldn't be
able to take it back i don't care who's
on it if they have the same phone 15
minutes nothing it stays
hard pardon what about photos the same
i don't do photos you do
we'll see how this goes when it comes
out
one more thing is coming up next hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now